[Musique]
une relation adultère voici le point de
départ de la pièce match à domicile
les comédiens sont tous des étudiants de
l'estaca une école basée à montigny le
bretonneux qui forme des ingénieurs dans
le secteur des transports
un univers un peu éloigné d'une scène de
théâtre
moi j'en ai fait j'ai commencé quand
j'étais petit j'avais 10 ans et c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours passionné
qui m'a toujours plus de pouvoir
m'exprimer autrement
et donc voilà j'ai voulu continuer parce
que ça me fait sortir des cours et de
thé mathématiques ce club théâtre est
subventionné à hauteur de 1400 euros par
l'école au cours de l'année des cours
ont lieu avec des metteurs en scène
professionnels
parmi les grands projets cette pièce
écrite par l'un des étudiants jean
baptiste aubert le sujet il est moderne
c'est sur les applications de rencontres
simples et une parodie de pin de kinder
puis qui s'appelle pender dans la pièce
justement mais on a essayé de traiter ça
de façon assez classique quand même avec
des voiles à des équipes rocco est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire une sorte de
vaudeville moderne dont matches à
domicile on retrouve les codes du
théâtre classique un mari trompé des
voisins qui débarque sans prévenir des
quiproquos
sur scène sept comédiens répètent depuis
septembre au minimum une fois par
semaine après les cours
je pierrick qui est un peu en voisin pas
très très gentil on va dire ça qui a
tendance à créer sur ses colocataires
qui a tendance à créer chez sa voisine
sur son voisin du dessus qui déteste sa
mère est bon globalement une même
personne c'est quelqu'un antipathique et
c'est la pire personne qui puisse
exister je pense
l'unique représentation de cette pièce
made in estaca aura lieu le jeudi 30
janvier à 18 heures dans l'auditorium
elle est ouverte à tous
ja